this is from the daily callers the
superstar billy eilish opened up about
how she started watching porn at around
the age of 11 and said she feels
watching it has destroyed her brain
a 19 year old singer shared during an
appearance on the howard stern show
as a woman i think porn is a disgrace i
used to watch a lot of porn to be honest
i started watching porn when i was like
11. i think it really destroyed my brain
i feel incredibly devastated that i was
exposed to so much porn
i'm so angry that porn is so loved and
i'm so angry at myself for thinking that
it was okay
the way that vaginas look in porn is
effing crazy no vaginas look like that
women's bodies don't look like that we
don't like that uh the first few times i
had sex i was not saying no to things
that were not good
it was because i thought that's what i
was supposed to be attracted to
okay i mean this is
on one hand if you want to look at from
the pessimistic angle it's uh it is
frustrating
that some of us have been saying this
about pornography for uh
for years
and we've been shouted down and mocked
and everything oh it's with port it's
just it's just images on a screen what's
the big deal
it's just a fantasy oh what do you mean
porn harms harms harms women oh that's
silly that's ridiculous
and now when a 19 year old pop star
starts saying it people take it a little
bit more seriously that's a pessimistic
angle of it but
you know
whoever the source needs to be i'm glad
that it's that that this is happening
and she's not the first one we this this
in fact is what we need we need people
yeah i mean someone like me i can
sit here all day and talk about that and
say what what a harm
um it is
but to a certain extent it's always
going to be dismissed as
religious puritanism or whatever
but billy eilish as far as i know
i'm assumed i could be wrong i'm
assuming not a not a devout christian
and she's telling you her own experience
she's not alone in this
in fact there's a there's a whole
generation of people if you would listen
to them
people about billy eilish's age
just now becoming adults
and uh they grew up with this stuff they
are the first generation that grew up
with online porn and i don't want to
hear anything from older people about oh
what are you talking about when i was a
kid there was a playboy under my dad's
mattress that whole canard
i mean if your dad had pornography under
his mattress and he was allowing you to
access it then your dad was a creep and
i'm sorry about that
but that is nothing like this
okay
magazines magazine images
on pieces of paper
nothing like the the permeation of
hardcore porn that children young
children i mean she says at age 11 she
started looking at this stuff
so these are prepubescent kids
she says it destroyed her brain she's
right
now fortunately the damage is not
permanent there's a way to
to overcome it i think
but there are certain effects that will
linger forever because this is during
your formative years
this is before puberty
um your idea of human sexuality is very
much shaped by all this stuff that
you're watching online
you get a little bit older and you
realize that it was shaped in this way
and misshaped by it then that's when you
could start to recover but but it does
it does have an effect
that to a certain extent i mean you know
i just said a second ago that it's not
permanent i think in fact some of the
damage actually is permanent
it won't it doesn't doom you to uh to a
dysfunctional
sex life or dysfunctional relationships
your whole life but it is there are
there is some permanent damage done
because of what these kids are being
exposed to how early they're being
exposed to it how much of it they're
exposed to how often
and so if you listen to the kids who are
not you know not kids now they're adults
but if you just listen to them so many
of them will say exactly this i grew up
with this
and i wish that i hadn't
you you
you'd be hard-pressed to find someone
who's 20 years old right now
and is happy
that they've been watching hardcore porn
since the age of eight years old you're
gonna you're gonna you'll be
hard-pressed to find somebody like that
you might you're gonna find plenty of
people who have not had this awakening
moment that billy eilish has where they
realize the damage that's done
but if you ask them if this you know if
they look back at their childhood their
life is has this helped them was that
time well spent do they wish they had
watched even more i think the answer to
all those questions is going to be no
so this is very very different from the
magazine under the mattress deal
these are kids that are exposed to the
most i mean the most
grotesque imagery that you can imagine
like images right from the bowels of
hell that have been brought up and
bubbled up and that our kids are now
their minds are marinating in
for years and years and years
does that cause trauma yeah it does
and if you don't believe that then think
about i mean
if you heard about a case of sexual
abuse
where a ten-year-old kid a nine-year-old
kid
was allowed to be in the room
while
something like what you would see in
porn was happening right in front of
them
okay
uh we would all agree that that is
sexual abuse that this is a that that
child is a sexual abuse victim
this is that he was molested even if he
wasn't physically touched he is a victim
of sexual abuse and molestation i think
we all agree with that i would hope we'd
all agree with that and that the adults
who were performing this sexual act in
front of the child
should go to prison
as sexual abusers
well if we could all agree that that is
traumatic sexual abuse then how is it
any different when the kid is viewing
this stuff on a screen
does that magically make
make it all okay does that does does
that screen act as some sort of
psychological or emotional barrier
where the damage that would be done if
they were in the same room isn't done
anymore it doesn't make any sense
if you agree that simply encountering
those images
and viewing an
act like this at that age if you agree
that that it can be
emotionally and psychologically
traumatic and damaging and and
tantamount to sexual abuse
if you agree that that's the case in
person then you should agree with that
in uh when it comes to pornography which
means
that we have an entire generation and
now multiple generations
of sexual abuse victims
like all of these kids
are sexual abuse victims because of what
they've been exposed to
that's also why i think that's that's
also why i think you may you can make a
very strong argument for banning this
stuff
because it is sexual abuse you're
putting this stuff out there
where you know that kids not only can
access it but millions of them are
every single day and you are
purposefully
making a contribution to that
contributing to the sexual abuse of
children
i think you could ban it on for that
reason alone
listen hit that subscribe button right
now do it right now i thank you for your
compliance it is
somewhat appreciated